good afternoon my name is Faisal
whelpley I have login information if
anybody's interested in logging in and
checking this out what I'm about to
demonstrate is a basically a learning
management system that we built with the
concept of online Mathematica so the
platform that we build was prior to
wolfram mathematica online being
released so what you're about to see is
our own custom implementation of it but
it does pretty much everything that you
expect Mathematica to do it is
mathematica on the web and I don't want
to spend too much time on the technology
itself short of showing you that some of
the implementation details not detail
some of the differences from Mathematica
that you probably cannot tell so this is
a styled Mathematica notebook it will do
evaluations just like Mathematica would
and you see the output is typeset you
can click on the output it converts to
the linear syntax input form which
allows us to do things like typeset
input cells or even using typeset in
text cells we do this by the control m
keyboard shortcut and when you click out
of that box that gets generated it will
type set that into a 2d expression so
you can click it back inside and change
your underlying input and click back
outside to make it retype set so each
types of spinning the server and this is
evaluative also i can evaluate it again
so now the second line should be a
number and not a function we handle
plots
just like you expect Mathematica to do
this are all Mathematica generated
output the mathematica is running on our
server and every call from evaluation is
getting sent back to the web browser I'm
running in firefox by the way if you are
going to be logging and checking it out
but I recommend using firefox or chrome
and nothing else so what we built is the
learning management system around this
technology this is how the instructor
interface looks there's the content for
all the courses that we support mostly
undergraduate college undergraduate
level I'll talk a little bit more about
the courseware right now pretty soon but
this these are some of the sample
student responses that we see the way
the coarser is presented is a completely
contained curriculum there's no
additional support to this but students
will be reading the text inside this
platform the this is an example question
with a I believe this is the Monte Carlo
simulation so the students asked to do
the Monte Carlo estimation here so they
have the code available to them in the
presented material that they can later
copy i believe the presenter material
talks about estimating the unit circle
and how the Monte Carlo is to estimation
comes really close to PI but now they
have to copy that code edit it to fit
this problem where they trying to
estimate the area for the bell curve to
figure out this percentage so this
everything in green shaded in green it's
done automatically within this learning
management system so the student John
Doe here type this text in type this
code in and it is clearly highlighted
for for visual effects we've also added
a canvas drawing so we can ask questions
like this draw a plot of something and
by double clicking on any graphics to
the graphics you can add to the plot
so just like you know just a sketching
program really and here's a sample
question that we have has student is in
the course where explain how the
distance formula works so the student
actually had to do some sketches throw
in some labels and write texts on on
explaining the idea behind the system is
there's no machine graded when a student
does this this is the student interface
when a student logs in on the left side
here they see a the syllabus like I said
it's a completely contained course so
basics and tutorials is where they get
presented the materials for the course
they read through evaluate any given
code much like the Wolfram programming
lab idea that that was demonstrated
during the keynote working code is
already given student have to just
evaluate and an infinity that's the
interaction that they get from the
program when they go to actually try an
assignment in the program then they get
to insert their own answer so this
answer gets handed in to astute to the
greater human greater receives that's
the handed button receives the
submission from the student which shows
up in a queue for them so this is an
example grading Q every student
submission that I am mentoring I am
working with will show up in this queue
and I have all sorts of filters that is
available for me so I can drill down to
a particular submission or a particular
student or a particular course and
clicking on this brings up that student
submission which I can then read now you
see why the highlight comes in handy I
can detect the students responses
immediately and then write my own
responses in there again gets
highlighted as mentors or instructors
feedback and I can send this back to the
student and the system is also set up to
new send out
email notification so every time this
interaction happens students have
control over students instructors
mentors have control over what kind of
email notification they get whenever
something exciting happens or not
exciting happens in the platform so this
encourages something really interesting
a format if assessment this is a student
that I was directly interacting with
that just did not get what the question
was asking for the first time around so
he just wrote a few things down and then
I'm creating a conversation creating a
dialogue with the student and i'm asking
him leading questions i'm telling him
why don't you maybe rephrase the
question this way and when he's again
attempting to follow the instruction
still cannot i'm still leading him never
never dropping never shying away from
that interaction with my students and
this probably happens like one percent
of the time usually they get it after
like the second time so formative
assessment basically allows students to
retry a problem instead of just getting
marked right or wrong so they can
further develop their understanding so
most of you should have access to the
account and I'm i forgot what account
you get the instructor interface which
looks like this contains all the courses
that we offer like I said undergraduate
level courses and you can take a peek at
the content based on the login that you
just received all the basics tutorials
try it and literacy now even though this
is a completely contained curriculum you
have the flexibility you have the
control over what content you actually
want to present to your student because
once you decide to teach a course you
can take that course and get a copy of
it
so you can call this my course so now
this is going to create a copy in in the
accordion down here if you can see
called my courses your own version of
that course this is where you as the
instructor get the flexibility of
choosing which assignment you would like
to your students to use or determining
the order in which you like these
chapters to be presented to your student
you can even introduce your own problem
set you can actually open these
notebooks and add edit them at will you
can you can toss up problems you can add
new problems you can do it pretty much
everything it is your copy of the
existing pre Kent course to edit at will
now once you're ready to teach once
you're ready comfortable with the
content you can stage the course and
then activate it an active course will
create a URL specific to that course
which you can then pass out to your
students students can go to that URL and
go through a signup process it is free
for instructors to set up this course
and activate the students when they sign
up for the course they buy this as if
they're purchasing a textbook that's the
that's the business model for this
platform so because it's a
self-contained course there's nothing
else to purchase they don't need an
additional text they don't need to
subscribe to any videos or any other
thing this is everything contained
within this one platform and we've we've
been actively using this to teach
especially at University of Illinois
they run an online math program called
net math is being run in a self-paced
rolling enrollment format so the
students are not even on site in the
classroom they're all over the world
doing everything on there
on time they get something like 16 weeks
to do the course the platform wise the
evaluation capabilities the hand in
capabilities you get six month is its
software as a service when they buy it
they get all the course content but they
also get the ability to evaluate in hand
in for up to six months so you can run a
course that is up to six months in
length within this platform so we don't
do any videos we don't do any lectures
that was not necessarily by design
that's just how it was a grown this
program is based on ideas that was
generated in the University of Illinois
around the same time Mathematica version
one was created by professors getting
together and trying to use Mathematica
as a piece of technology in the
classroom so what they started doing was
to teach lecture session and then they
would create these Mathematica notebooks
which eventually became the course rivet
that we are using and then use send the
students to the lab to plug away at the
computer and they started noticing
dramatic reduction in lecture attendance
and yet students were developing key
understanding with the concept and based
on student feedback they decided to not
do lectures completely and spend all
their class hours inside the computer
lab and the feedback was not exactly
great because students were basically
going while at the computer but
developing some misunderstanding
developing some problems so they sort of
have already started doing this blended
model of introducing the students
through the material first in the
classroom in front of the computer and
then at the end of the week making a
discussion section and then that that's
when they found that students are coming
in to the discussion sections with
having seen the concepts of the
materials beforehand and then are able
to engage actively in discussion with
the instructor so this is what was
developing the understanding of the
material
in the students so one other point I
wanted to touch is oh yeah so it's
instructor-led even though instructor is
not the one that's presenting the
information to the students the students
are directly accessing the material and
mathematica mix that allows that to
happen there even 20 years ago obviously
20 years ago that was the only piece of
technology that was around and that's
why this quarter was started to build in
Mathematica but even now after being a
mathematica user for 10 years I still
find the mathematica interface the dough
book interface especially in in
collaboration with the Wolfram language
is definitely the by far the best tool
for teaching because it allows students
once you provide the code working code
that explains the concept that does the
computation now the students can can go
wild and take that and run it our
students can produce manipulate to
support an argument or a conclusion that
they arrived by themselves based on the
questions asked in the coursework and I
think that's Tessa as a fundamental idea
there where the students are immersed in
the medium in the platform that they are
working in they don't have to switch
between digital media to paper or even
listening to a lecture to a different
computation platform everything is
inside one platform even the learning
management system of handing in work and
receiving feedback the the student in a
can even see directly what the grades
are are they should if you assign due
dates that even be due date
notifications if if and when an
assignment is about to be do so
everything is the student gets not only
immersed in this platform but they
actively immersed because they actually
have to produce they have to write full
sentences explaining an answer they not
they're not just providing an answer if
a student submits an assignment that I'm
grading and I see they have provided an
answer to a computation I would send
that back to the students asking them to
explain how they arrived at this
computation and because of the built in
formatted for Sesame system I can do
that and
basically essentially coaxing out of
them the words describing the top
process and that's the key element in in
the system also because they essentially
working in mathematical notebooks
directly there's nothing preventing them
from making mistakes which is another
key piece of an key element to learning
when they make mistakes and and and
figure out something or break something
that again can be used as a discussion
to further deepen the understanding of
the subject material does everybody have
if you try to access the website and you
have problem you can always reach me at
Faisal at making math calm or there's a
there's the email on our front website
in case you need to reach us let's see
the Skip anything else